now joe biden tonight continues to say
no to american energy as we've been
discussing continues to say no to
restoring energy independence here with
reaction former keystone
xl pipeline worker neil crabtree is with
us along with ohio republican
congressman jim jordan neil let me start
with you
uh you heard the premier of alberta say
within a year we can we can have 900 000
barrels of oil pumped through that
pipeline a day
uh
how close were we to finishing that
pipeline
well uh we've got to remember just
because president biden
gives his okay that we're still dealing
with an injury company that lost
billions of dollars uh the first time
around so they're going to be very
hesitant to come back to the united
states without some kind of concessions
you know if i was that energy company i
would say hey
you're going to have to give me some of
my money back that i lost the first time
around and you're going to have to give
me some concrete proof that we're not
going to end up in u.s courts again but
as far as building the pipeline uh hey
we got the workforce that can do it in
in about eight months time we'll have
that pipeline up and running and i'm
tired of hearing that this is going to
take three let me ask you a question no
sir
i interviewed other pipeline workers and
and you all were making pretty good
money these were high paying skill
specific career jobs right
because yes the reason i took a lot of
pride in it it is a career
and and you guys were working hard how
did you feel when you heard that
not only was your project canceled but
almost simultaneously a waiver was given
to vladimir putin for the nordstrom 2
pipeline how'd that make you feel
uh i mean we take a lot of pride in what
we do and and and i'm not trying to be
sounding like a wimp here but it it
broke our hearts you know
we take a lot of pride in producing
american energy we want to do it here at
home
and
let me just say something
i take no pride in saying what i'm about
to say right now but the president of
the united states is lying to you when
he says that his policies have nothing
to do with the prices of energy they
have everything to do with the prices
going up uh and i'm glad you had
congressman jim jordan on with me
tonight and he can back me up on this
i've set in congressional hearings where
they called every ceo in from the major
companies in this country and they told
them they're going to stop producing
energy and he's the only one who stood
up and said no this is wrong so yes joe
biden your policies have everything to
do with what's going on in this country
right now let me
jim jordan you know if we would open up
the the gas uh potential of ohio west
virginia pennsylvania that'd be huge
you're listening to neil's story here
and i i just frankly it makes no sense
to me maybe it'll make sense to you or
you can make sense of it
no this is the great divide
in america today sean you got the quote
elite and the crazy left who think that
there's no problem having four and five
dollar gas and then you got middle
america you got the with the working in
middle class american families who
understand what this this means so this
is the great even you had colbert say oh
just get a go go buy a tesla and buddha
dead said you know buy buy an electric
vehicle the disdain they have for the
people in manufacturing and the people
in agriculture the people who make
things and grow things is what just bugs
me to death i mean remember when peter
strzok said
i'm in the walmart and i can smell the
trump supporters or when anderson cooper
said you know trump supporters they they
eat at the olive garden and stay at the
marriott i mean the disdain the quote
elite the the left have for the people
in this country who make it happen is
what drives me crazy and we're seeing
that play out people like mr crabtree
are what make this country such a
special place and they're getting a raw
deal from the biden administration jim
jim jordan you'll stay with us uh mr
crabtree i agree with jim tell
i thank you and your fellow workers uh
for all the great work you've done hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else